hey guys my name is Jess and it is
Friday he is the biggest things that
happened in gaming this week apart from
no man's sky warping into your life
tequila works the studio that made dead
light has been working on the iOS crime
for a good three years now and we
finally got some new info where I'm is
described as a single-player puzzle
adventure game slated for a 20-17
release the alleged ps4 exclusive may
not actually end up coming exclusively
to the Sony platform after all this week
grey box and six foot announced they
would be helping tequila works publish
rhyme next a year these guys recently
published the RTS grey goo earlier this
year tequila works reacquired the rights
to the game and parted ways with Sony
they're publishing partner at the time
this week's press release indicator that
gameplay and platform availability
details will be shared early next year
Pokemon go oh yes people are still
playing that game got an update this
week and here's what's changed the
nearby feature which was kind of very
broken has been replaced by sightings
sightings shows off Pokemon in the
vicinity and aims to help aid in
tracking the critters without revealing
exact location as third-party Services
has been doing the new feature looks
like it will now show Pokemon that have
appeared near post up the patch notes
also indicate that developer niantic
have made improvements to Pokemon
catching implemented bug fixes and added
in notification dialog reminding you not
to try to catch pokemon while you're
driving if it's a texture going above a
certain speed next up a newly published
Nintendo patent could be strongly
hinting at what we can expect from the
NS last month a report suggested that
the upcoming NX system would feature
detachable controllers and if this new
patent is anything to go by that could
well be the case neoga uncovered the
patient which describes an accessory
that can be attached to the outside of a
so called information processing device
the accompanying illustrations look an
awful lot like a sort of controller that
can be attacked
to the main device but i'll let you be
the judge of that one the patent also
mentions an infrared camera for the
handheld device which can determine what
inputs on the accessory are being
utilized the NX is due out in March of
next year Nintendo isn't the only major
publisher with a console on the way
though as it seems Sony have been
getting pretty busy on the near brunch
according to reports by game blog and
vice Sonia planning to officially unveil
the more powerful ps4 neo at an event in
new york on sep tember seven previous
reports had suggested that the system
could be released before the end of the
year Sony have indicated that the neo is
intended to sit alongside and complement
the standard ps4 much like Microsoft are
planning to do with the upcoming more
powerful version of the xbox one
codenamed project Scorpio finally
there's been some confusion in no man's
sky it's to praise meet up but can't
actually see each other after expressing
some excitement that it was possible for
players to find one another in the game
director Sean Murray hasn't really
explained why players in the same
location wouldn't see each other the sad
cactus and Saito cat coordinated to meet
and although they could see the same
world and each has its discoveries they
couldn't actually physically spot each
other in their respective games it's
suspected that perhaps this is down to
the fact that the game doesn't render
player model server issues or that each
player exists in their own instance of
the game which are not shared with other
players this week on site we let you
know how to get your hands on an atlas
pass in no man's sky talk about whether
titanfall to benefits from single player
and we eat Pokemon themed donuts because
why they have a lot that is everything I
happy this week be sure to have
yourselves a lovely weekend and the
Americans will be taking care of you
next week so I'll see you after that